we'll get to iran in just a second first
some breaking news tigran rebels have
taken control of a place called
lalibella
in northern ethiopia the unesco world
heritage sites in
amara is holy for christians fighting in
tigray has spilled over into neighboring
regions in recent weeks thousands of
people have been forced to leave
and to flee the violence malcolm webb is
following that development for us out of
nairobi malcolm
what's going on there as far as we can
tell
well residents and others have told us
that fighters from the tigray region
have entered that historic town
lalabella
there were rumors that they were close
among local residents over the last week
some of the residents said they've heard
gunfire at night but they say it's
normal to
to hear some gunfire at night there but
then just in the last few hours
residents said they could see their
the gray and people's liberation front
fighters
uh getting close uh and then just a
short while ago they've taken
control of the town it's a town with a
population of 20 or so
thousand people but it couldn't be of
greater religious
and cultural and historical uh
significance it's 800 years old full of
uh
ancient churches and it's a
holy site for ethiopia's millions of
orthodox christians
but this is also uh as well appears to
be a significant
incursion on the part of the tigrayan
people's liberation front from the north
coming into the territory of the of
their enemy they've been fighting with
uh amara militia to the south and now it
seems they've
taken control of this town that's well
inside uh
their enemies territory but it's careful
to remember that in this conflict there
aren't contingent front lines to speak
of
uh people control a town here another
other controller town there so we can't
uh we can't guess at how much territory
has taken but certainly this is as far
as we've known they've take
taken the town into their enemies
territory so far that conflict of course
has been
spreading into the amara and afar
regions
in the last few weeks is this region or
is this town malcolm strategically
important or is it the fact that they've
taken it
the signaling of the fact that they've
taken it the important thing here
well in terms of strategic importance
it's hard to say if
you know what presence they actually
have in the surrounding area
if they've got supply lines if they've
taken broader territory
uh so i mean taking uh just one town we
you know we don't know
much more about about it but the
significance of it couldn't be
greater it's considered one of the sort
of founding sites of ethiopia
visiting successive visiting heads of
state have been brought
here to you know to show them his one of
ethiopia's greatest
historic sites and it's a particular
importance to the amhara people
themselves so certainly a a a
a a a great knock to uh to to
to their to their to that side in the
conflict the fact that their enemy has
come in and uh taken
uh one of their most holy uh and
historic sites right
inside their territory okay malcolm many
thanks malcolm webb there in nairobi